in today's eight on your side with more  of us shopping online for black friday  and in general due to the pandemic  there's been an 80 increase in hacking  and phishing scams that's according to  checkpoint  a cyber security company that's been  doing research for the past 25 years on  these types of attacks around the globe  to help people protect themselves the  company issued a number of safety tips  credential theft is a huge goal of cyber  attacks  mainly because people reuse their  credentials  often across accounts so if they can get  your credentials for one account  they might have access to multiple  accounts  so never share those credentials folks  that's really important be suspicious of  password reset emails  and two good to be true bargains we'll  have more coming up tonight at 5.